hello everyone and Welcome to our Max
site sponsored event titled Beyond
affinity and a body Discovery
optimization and developability
screening from a Malian display
libraries my name is Leslie eschinger
and I am the director of Market
development maxsite I will be your
moderator for today's engaging session
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
submit them to ask a question box and
click Send
we'll also answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical
questions or technical issues here as
well if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
I am really excited today to introduce
our speaker for today's session Peter
slavny is the chief technology officer
and co-founder of iontus and is directly
responsible for delivering the antibody
Discovery and protein engineering
portfolio for the company
Peter has led numerous successful
biotherapeutic drug Discovery campaigns
with several resulting molecules now
entering the clinic thank you for
joining us today Peter we look forward
to this informational session you may
now begin your presentation
[Music]
hello everyone uh good afternoon or good
morning depending on whereabouts in the
world you're joining us from today
um so uh
I'm glad to be talking with you about
our main display platform and I'm going
to start the presentation today with a
very brief one slide introduction to the
company take you through an introduction
to the remainder space system that we're
using and then go on to a couple of case
studies one regarding Affinity
maturation using the main display and
another on developability engineering
so the company is divided into free
Brands and we have a fair Journey
biologics which is a service provider
brand doing antibody Discovery and
Engineering Services
floating which is a protein science
brand focused on antibody production
biophysical characterization and
developability assessment to pre-cmc
and finally ion tasks which focuses on
Cutting Edge
Technologies which supports antibody and
protein engineering and amongst those is
the main display technology which is the
subject of today's presentation
so if we may start at the beginning the
beginning the very beginning I
appreciate this slide maybe very basic
for for some of the audience here but
nonetheless just so we're on the same
wavelength there are a variety of
properties we need uh when trying to
find a therapeutic antibody which comes
together to make our desired you know
Target product profile or the list of
tick boxes that we want in order to have
a therapeutic they include Affinity
um uh which is in some ways to start a
potency and sometimes the relationship
is Trivial sometimes it's not as we know
function
of course I need to do the thing you
want otherwise you don't have a drug a
specificity so that can be for example
uh not recognizing a close human
homologue for toxicity concerns or it
could be cross-reacting to a species of
log Sino urine antigens for pre-clinical
development
of course finally but no less
importantly the molecule needs to be
well behaved so you need to actually be
able to manufacture it
um and that relates to its biophysical
properties production and regenicity and
various other things
so you know of course the earlier we can
screen for each of these things and in
the higher frequent we can do so the
better the chance of hitting this sweet
spot in the middle and getting the
molecule that we really want first time
in addition to screening early in high
throughput it also matters that your
assays your screening assays are
actually predictive of the downstream
properties that you want so for example
your functional assay is unlikely to be
a clinical trial so it's a surrogate for
the function that you need
um and likewise uh manufacturability
assessments and developability
assessments can report different
properties of your potential therapeutic
and some of them are more meaningful or
predictive than others for the final
property so we need to screen in as high
throughput as possible and also using
metrics or assays that are actually
predictive of the final drug that we
want to make
which brings us to how does mammalian
display help us do this
the firstly
um traditional technologies have
involved individual picking of clones
you know from face display or amino
across hyperdomas
um it's going out of single cells as
well
um and screening so main display allows
or should allow the ability to use flow
cytometry or facts for selection and
look at many millions of Clans
in doing so you can gain information on
the expression level and infer something
then about the Affinity as well as the
finding and importantly it will allow us
to work in the final format which is
often an IGG but not always an IGG and
there are other very interesting final
formats um which could be useful to
start on day one by specifics camera
connection receptors and others
also it will allow us to screen directly
in the cell type used for production and
we got a lot more than we bargained for
uh on that one and that's something I'll
come back to later as it relates to
availability
and finally there's a potential to
screen for the desired function fairly
early on
so this is so desirable what's been the
the reason it's taken so long uh well
the key challenge here is to make a
library large enough with a single dream
per self in other words to maintain
their genotype phenotype linkage and
have a working selection system and our
particular solution to that problem is
to use uh nuclear genetic integration to
generate Library members
so it was discovered some time ago that
by introducing a double strand break in
the genome you can increase the
efficiency of homologous recombination
about 40 000 folk and this is true
regardless of the nucleus you use and so
some of those are listed here Mega
nucleus is zinc finger Tau nucleosis and
of course more recently Charisma has
nine and there's a crystal structure
here by Megan nucleus about to DNA so
we've used all of these and our system
is actually agnostic to which nucleos
you use the important thing is to induce
a double strand break and drive
recombination
so this is how the system works overall
we have what we call a donor cassette
which encodes in this case I'm showing
you an IGG with a light chain and a
heavy chain and a two separate promoters
but actually this is a piece of plasma
DNA and it can be anything you put into
a plasmid so it's really a modular
system and the input can be anything you
can plan which could be of course IGG or
other formats as well and we've worked
with several it also has a promotionless
blaster siding resistance cassette and
homology arms at the left and right and
these match a Target uh intro in the
genome
so what we do is we transfect this along
with a nucleus the nucleus drives a
double strand break in the DNA in the
DNA in the genome and this drives
integration of the transgene into the
slice of Interest
if this happens correctly this
promotionless Blaster siding goes in
frame with an industrial and spliced
onto an endogenous axon and gives an
antibiotic resistance marker selectable
Locker
to do this we're using the Maxi STX
system and of course we're very happy
with it otherwise I will be giving this
talk today
okay so there are a variety of things we
can do with this system so the first I'm
showing you here is to check that the
resulting cell lines that are made using
this actually depending on nucleus and
therefore are being integrated into the
right place and you can see in this
Colony assay that we have a very high
proportion of nucleus dependent uh
elasticizing resistant colonies in other
words it's a very efficient mechanism
for delivering the transgen into the
correct place
and we're typically seeing 98 plus these
days for these kind of experiments
we need to show that we can actually see
the antibody so in this case you're
looking at uh facts of a single antibody
inserted uh using anti-human FC on the
x-axis and lysoside which is the
estrogen on the y-axis I'm sure many of
you will be able to guess the antibody
that we're using for this and you can
see display and you can see binding to
the action as we might expect in a
relationship that we might expect
between those two
and finally but absolutely critically we
need to show that we can do this at
scale with a single Gene per cell so
what we did to test this is took a mix
of two different antibodies uh one
against fgfr1 and one against fgfr2
makes them 50 50 which is the same as
one to one
um put them into the system generate
your cell lines and then stain with both
antigens so here you've got fgfr1
on the y-axis and fgfr2 on the x-axis
and what you can see is that this mixed
population resolves itself very neatly
into two distinct populations with very
few double positives less than five
percent so this shows that I should say
we did this at scale with millions of
clouds
so this demonstrates that we're getting
efficient integration and that we're
doing so
in the vast majority of cases 95 plastic
cases with a single Gene per cell and we
are now routinely using this system to
discover an engineering antibodies from
a variety of inputs I mentioned already
that the input is plasmid DNA so it's a
modular system and we've used this in
combination with Focus libraries from
phase display with immune repertoires
and naive repertoires and of course with
de novo
um engineering repertoire so individual
sequences which are being engineered uh
for the sake of time I'm going to show
you just one quick example is actually
the first project we did uh of an
affinity maturation
so in this case we were taking a pd1
antibody a parental antibody is shown
here potential in the main display
system
and we wanted to engineer improved
affinity for that
so by traditional methods for example
nns which we've done for comparison you
see that the vast majority of mutations
are deleterious in in the remaining
system you can actually see those the
fat stuff right here and you can see
there's basically a few that are good
within that and of course space display
and other systems are very powerful and
can pick out these very rare events here
we wanted to try a slightly different
approach a more focused approach
actually describing as a total synthesis
so here what we did is take the heavy
Studio free which happens to be eight
amino acids and use modern techniques
for direct synthesis of every single
Library member
um and do so in a way which you tasted
basically every combination of two
changes Away From the Block type so in
doing so you get a set of daughter
claims which uh differ from the parental
sequence by two amino acids with every
combination of two changes and that
works out as around 9 000 variants in
the heavy cdf3
we do the same in the light CD offering
and that gives us a combined diversity
that's manageable within the system and
that really focuses around on the wild
type sequence information we call this a
search of the local sequence space
and you can see immediately
that when you do this
um there's a much higher proportion of
clones in this quadrant here showing
that fewer of the variance of
deleterious as you would expect with a
soft image Genesis strategy
so we took these libraries using the
methods I just described to introduce
the minimum alien cells made a library
around the one 10 to the seven Mark uh
did some fact selection Affinity ranking
some functional screening and we're
going to join the story fairly close to
the end of the stage of processing
so what I'm showing you here are results
from a checkpoint inhibition assay it's
a commercial assay from Omega
where blockade of the pd01 pd1 axis
relieves repression or an NFL reporter
element resulting in luciferase
production and what you see here are the
parental antibody shown in Orange The
Benchmark of Battalion The Villa map of
Devo shown in red and the matured
variant from the main display shown in
blue
so you can see we've been able to
engineer this antibody to have improved
potency relative to The Benchmark at the
time
in this case the potency Improvement
correlated well with an affinity
Improvement and you can see again my spr
the parental antibody here the mature
current from the main display in the
middle and a little about the Benchmark
on the right and the same pattern as we
saw for the postness the essay just
previously
okay so I want to change tax slightly
now and start to talk about
developability and how we can use my
main display for developability
engineering and also a little bit of the
story of how we we came to realize that
so
I mentioned already that it's not enough
to be able to have uh clones with the
correct finding properties specificities
and so on but we also need to
manufacture them so this means cost
efficient uh production of cost
efficient production of goods
um and often increasingly stable at high
concentration for subcutaneous
Administration and of course shelf life
and other aspects as well
so
uh
a good starting point for this we felt
was
um the genital paper uh which did a big
service to the to the field uh back in
2017 uh where they looked at a variety
of clinical stage antibodies and put
them through a whole Suite of
compatibility assays and really surveyed
the landscape of the biophysical
properties of the of the clinical stage
antibodies
so there are a wide variety of different
uh
methods available for generating
antibodies some of them are listed here
and of course whichever one we use we
all know that it's possible for things
to to fail later on reducing
availability once they get into the
clinic and so we wanted to use the
available data from Jane and colleagues
um to question can we address student
availability with the main display
earlier than would be done previously
and also more effectively
so the place we started was to go and
reproduce
some of the work that's been done using
other first cytometry based selection
systems so in this case what I'm showing
you is a detection of prereactivity poly
reactivity differences between Asta
kilimab which is marketed as Stelara and
Brian
which is was before in phase three and
in this case we're standing with either
Heparin or heat shot proteins and you
can clearly see that we can
differentiate these two antibodies based
on binding to these these antigens
in the process of doing this we made an
observation so we observed uh when
looking at these clinical stage
antibodies described by genital
um
that
there was a difference in the IGG
display level on mammalian cells
which was correlated with the
biophysical Behavior
um
but interestingly it wasn't sufficiently
explained by differences in soluble
expression so to put that another way
um the display level of IGG antibodies
on the surface of mammalian cells
appeared to be giving a measure not just
of the ability to fold and produce them
but of the colloidal stability so of the
biophysical properties in solution and
this we thought was very interesting and
worth looking at in more detail
so we went back to the literature and we
identified some pairs of antibodies
whereby there was a parental clone that
had biophysical problems
and an improved daughter clone which has
been engineered to alleviate those
biophysical issues and also where there
were similar levels of expression so I'm
showing you two pairs of antibodies for
the literature described by Dobson their
talent Buchanan Hotel
um and everything that we looked at from
those papers reproduced very nicely
so these antibodies have in the same
system we're using from the main display
hack system modest differences in
expression
no differences in the melting
temperature or tiag between the the good
guy and the bad guy
um but do start to have differences when
you look at the biophysical properties
in solution so color stability and this
is consistent as I mentioned with what's
reported
so what we see when we put these into
the main display system is that there is
more than a log separation between the
parental antibody
the bad guy and the improved version the
good guy
so a big difference in display
but not a big difference in expression
and we believe the display is reporting
the biophysical properties in solution
of these antibodies
so we know we can separate a good guy
from a bad guy the next question was
okay can we generate a library and
actually select for Approved variants
from a library
so to do that we went to slightly more
detail on one of these antibodies which
is this top one medi1912
so here we looked at the positions which
were reported to be causing some of
these biophysical problems for the
parental antibody uh randomize them just
by nns and selected for variance with
maintained antigen binding and also
improved display level on mammalian
cells
and the table here on the right shows
you some of the data for that so here's
the parental antibody which again
um
has a limited C max if C-Max is is a
relatively uncommon technique but it's
concentrating the protein by
ultrafiltration and it's giving you the
maximum concentration you can achieve by
outer filtration before you start to
lose material so it's kind of a
solubility measure
and it also has problems as mentioned by
DLS with the Z average here you can see
the improved version again that recovers
this C-Max and recovers the Z average of
the ls as well and we've identified a
set of different substitutions here
which basically match the improved
version but with different solutions
that these amino acid positions and as
judged by the C-Max and also the Z
average and quality diversity index as
well again you can see the differences
here
and I mentioned already that there was
no real difference in TM and tiag for
some of these
so
this
um was particularly interesting to us
because for many of these methods uh you
need a reasonable amount of protein and
the current throughput is typically tens
perhaps hundreds depending on your setup
of antibodies that you can put through
these kind of higher level 30 assays
which are reporting biophysical
properties in solution or colloidal
stimulating but this opens uh the door
potentially to doing this on a flow
cytometer not other level of tens or
hundreds but at the level of millions or
tens of millions and also to do so
simultaneously
uh with analysis and finding properties
and specificity and so on so this is
what got us excited I want to give you
one more example of applying this now
so this example is uh broadcasting lab
was a high-profile phase-free clinical
trial failure it started out life as a
mouse hybrid Omer was humanized to an
antibody called 5a10i
that was Affinity matured by phase
display taking it from 300 picomola down
to five picomola
but in doing so led to multiple
developability red flags according to
janetal including evidence of
self-interaction and low specificity
um and ultimately uh resulted probably
in the phase three uh clinical trial
failure and there was of course
significant immunogenicity found I think
about half of patients producing
anti-dog antibodies in the space free
trial
so we took 5a10i the uh kind of parent
antibody and the matured version of
kismab put them into the main display
system once again you can see that the
difference in development properties
is reflected by poorer cell surface
display and again this was produced and
formulated and went all the way to phase
three so it wasn't an obvious difference
in expression
and we wondered if we can fix blockages
map by my main display
so we looked at the crystal structure
which was available
um for blockchainab in complex with its
Target pcsk9 identified residues shown
here in hcdr1 hcdr2 and hcdr3 some of
these were paratopic and some were
non-paratopic
and residues in the VR I should say as
well so we took these introduced them to
make constructed a library of variants
introduce them into the main display
system and again we're standing here and
looking for expression of the antibodies
on X and action binding on the Y and
negated clones which maintained antigen
binding
um that had improved display and you can
see that for the VL Library they were
more paratopic positions targeted and
that's the difference in these two dot
Parts you can see
we recovered the antibody genes uh
electric sequences expressed to Unique
antibodies and characterized them by
physically of the 90 or so antibodies we
produced and tested by AC synths every
single antibody coming from the main
display was improved uh compared to
blockchained by SC since but I'm going
to show you a more comprehensive set of
data just for the most enriched clones
by my main display
so what I'm showing you here is the cdr2
sequence in the first uh column here
and these are positions which were
mutated and I'm showing you the amino
acid that's been changed in those
positions uh this is for blockchainab
the three most enriched variants in the
main display in the enrichment Factor
shown here
5a10i the precursor and aloe rocker map
which is a common control that we use as
an example of a well-behaved antibody
and what you can see is that there's a
big Improvement by AC Sims uh so an AC
synthesis measure of self-association
high score is bad a low score is good
and you can see that these the main
display enriched variants
um are in aligned with the Positive
controls at a rocky map and the the
precursor and obviously improve versus
blockchainab uh retention in hprc SEC is
also improved
interestingly poly specificity score has
also gone down to these antibodies
compared to block akizimab there is
actually having said this isn't all due
to expression there is a modest
Improvement uh in expression yield and I
think we'll there's an additional
benefit in cost of goods throwing it as
a side order we'll take that but that's
not the key driver of what we're doing
here and importantly if you look also by
DLS at 40 Mega Mills so this is quite a
high concentration of protein and the Z
average you can again see the improved
variants are in line with the
well-behaved allo rocker Mount control
so overall we see improved
um
biophysical properties as a relation to
Solution by physics of the main display
in Rich variants across a whole range of
different metrics
I also mentioned that
um Bok kizumab showed immunogenicity in
its phase three clinical trial and we
wanted to see whether or not the
engineering work we'd done on the Block
Is Now by physics by a main display had
any impact on its immunistic properties
so what you see here is a T Cell
proliferation assay from 10 happy type
donors and you see those donors either
separately on the right or as a combined
response index on the left I want to
draw your attention to Dr kissimmab here
which shows immunogenicity in this in
vitro to yourself for Liberation assay
um
as do the patrols and any eye here which
is the most enriched my main display
variant as well as his other Marine
display variant next to it
um which are in line with the Positive
controls in both the combined response
index and also in the individual donors
so it appears that
the engineering of bookism out by the
main display to improve its biophysical
properties has also ablated its
immunogenicity at least in the future in
this particular assay
it's also worth noting that
um the mutations present in these
variants which are highlighted here in
yellow
and I don't coincide with any predicted
T Cell appetite so this Improvement in
the immunogenicity properties of
rocketismab appears to be an emergent
property or in a trans effect of
improving the biophysical properties
rather than any direct effect on T-cell
appetites
so finally I just want to start and try
and tie some of these things together
into a hypothesis about what's happening
here so to do that I want to just take
you back to some data I showed you
already which is showing the top two
boxes here this is the display level of
two pairs of antibodies the good guy and
the bad guy
um and two or medi1912 showing a
parental in um blue and the improved
antibody in Orange and you can see this
log difference between the good guy and
the bad guy
when we do the same thing in yeast
display and this was done by
collaborators shown here this difference
in display level simply isn't apparent
or isn't apparent to the same extent so
this is interesting because
this difference which we know is
reporting biophysical behavior in
solution
um it's apparent in the remaining system
and it isn't apparent in the yeast
system
and that leads us to a hypothesis of
what's going on whereby in the mammalian
system antibodies are are forced for a
concentration bottleneck at the surface
of the cell so they can only occupy a
certain amount of space shown here and
you can even if you want work out the
copy number and the effective
concentration in a small space so that's
one
aspect
my contrast in the yeast system there's
actually a cell wall and the antibodies
can be placed along it and the effective
concentration is likely to be lower
and in addition to that in the use
system it's more or less a one-way trip
so the antibody gets to the surface and
that's it is there in the remaining
system another critical difference as
well as the concentration fossil neck is
that we think it's a dynamic system so
under that context
we believe that antibodies which are
prone to self-associating aggregate or
potentially to interact with other
proteins on the cell surface might be
internalized and reduced and so the
display level in the mammalian system a
forces the antibodies for a
concentration bottleneck and B is
dynamic so is probably an equilibrium
position requiring yes expression and
presentation on the surface but also
requiring uh maintaining the antibody at
high concentration on the surface and
not being internalized so that is our
hypothesis to explain a why we're able
to differentiate between the good guys
and the bad guys and the select improved
variants based on colloidal stability in
mammalian cells and by that doesn't
appear to be the case at least in our
hands in use display
foreign
ly I just like to take you through what
we've shown today so
um we've shown that you can display
antibodies directly on mammalian cells
and you can generate many millions of
cell lines in effect
of antibodies driven from the same Locus
expressed a million cells the input to
this is modular so plasmid and we can
use naive immunosynthetic repertoires as
an input for that or of course a
pre-enriched populations from your
preferred engine of choice for
generating diverse panels of binders you
can do this in IGG or in our final
formats and you can screen tens of
millions of clones Supermarket
parametric flow cytometry as a sorting
method I haven't spoken about it but it
also gives the potential to screen
directly for function for example by
cells producing and responding to an
encoded antibody or by direct screening
for example of cars
uh we can do all this importantly uh in
the context of de-risking availability
of these programs so we've shown that
you can detect uh clones with
developability issues particularly
self-association and point of activity
uh We've shown that you can select
improved variants of problematic loans
and of course the ideal is to avoid
those altogether by selecting the rights
clone in the first instance
finally I just want to thank you for
your attention today and also if anyone
is Keen to know more about this you're
also currently recruiting multiple
positions and would be happy for you to
join us the link is here and you can um
give us a touch
uh here are contact details for iontas
and our other brands for 1838 and fair
Journey biologics
finally uh we'll take any questions
thank you very much
all right thank you very much Peter for
that very informative presentation so as
a reminder we will now start the live q
a portion of the webinar if you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now you just click on the ask a
question box located in the left corner
of your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time before so
let's go ahead and get started uh first
question Peter were you surprised to see
correlation of display level with poly
specificity as well as self-association
yeah good question so I think initially
we were a bit but then you know when you
kind of step back and think about it uh
these are both kinds of alternative ways
of looking at protein stickiness
basically so you know
um self-association is the protein
sticking to itself and poly specificity
is it sticking to to other proteins so
so in a way there is a kind of an
underlying link between those two
parameters although we were perhaps a
surprise at the extent to which they
correlated and it's also something an
area of Act of Interest actually to see
if we can tease apart more subtlety um
in that area and of course you know
people like Peter Tessier and others
have done a lot of work characterizing
the different kinds of
um developability parameters and in that
example I think uh tells you describes
blockokizimab as a kind of class three
so a polyspecific antibody rather than
necessarily A self-associating
antibodies but clearly there are
commonalities underlying those depending
on the conditions you're using
perfect next question slash comment came
because coming in from tune excellent
webinar similar correlation between
mammalian expression and biophysical
behavior for non-igg scaffolds example
vhh and then has that been
experimentally assessed uh excellent
question
um vhh is has been experimentally
accessed and there is a same correlation
and we've actually done work with many
different kinds of of formats so
um why I'm trying constructs two chain
constructs free train constructs
um and antibodies non-antibodies
different types of antibodies so you
know we strongly believe at the moment
that this display level correlation is a
measure by physics is probably Universal
at least the way we've set up our main
display system it's not necessarily
going to be true you know for example in
our system you have genetic uh Symphony
so for example these are all integration
the same Locus some of you that as a
kind of transcriptional normalization
but at least in the system we've got we
think this is a universal feature I.E
you can separate probably all proteins
based on aspects of their Solution by
physics which is obviously
you know very useful for us absolutely
all right next question comes in from
Sarah how do you cope with antibody
internalization on the cell surface and
in parentheses when incubated with
antigens
and so that's so I think you know
there's two aspects to this so when we
probe we're obviously staining and we're
standing using similar methods that
others use for first symmetry so it's
low temperature so at the time of the
antigen and the stain we typically have
a low temperature and so we're stopping
internalization that way but of course
when we're probing the antibody on the
surface what you're seeing is a picture
that's developed you know as an
equilibrium over the time of culture in
those cells right so the internalization
will be a function will will represent
antibody properties at 37 degrees the
ability to maintain it on the surface as
I described but during oxygen staining
for the last kind of hour or so of their
existence there you know they're um
their spare that internalization
parameter that's a good question
okay perfect
um have you done any work with buy
specific antibodies in mammalian display
excuse me and can you use the system to
identify by specifics with optimal
developability properties
so yeah I guess kind of slightly related
to the the previous question I gave you
a bit of information on that so I
mentioned we've done what I'm trying to
train and free train constructs and the
the biophysical uh differences or the
differences that the ability to read out
by physical differences based on display
level applies across all of those in
addition to that we've done some initial
proof of concept work regarding the
display of knobs into holes by specifics
and the kind of optimized methods for
efficient display of the heterodimer on
the surface of the cell and that's as
much as I'm able to say currently on
that
thank you for giving us what you can
um next question do you use mammalian
display for pro Discovery projects as
well as a 30 maturation and if so how
often do you use it for Discovery yeah
okay so I think you know when we started
doing this we had and as the the first
case study I showed you
um
hinted that we had it in mind as a kind
of maturation being the core strength
here where often people try to mature
antibodies down to really good
affinities in doing so they kind of
break them uh and people talk about the
concept of needy antibodies you know and
so on and but in practice actually the
take-up has been on both and it's
actually about 50 50 it's a directly
answer the question about proportion
it's been about 50 50 for Discovery and
optimization
um and so we do use it for both although
I think you know maybe the things that
you're pushing for in the parameters you
might want to select on maybe very
slightly depending on the starting point
and the desired endpoint of course
perfect and we don't have any more
questions in the chat but feel free to
use that ask a question box we'll give
it a couple more minutes and see if
anything else comes in
um
here
all right not seeing anything else
coming in
um well Peter maybe I'll ask you at this
point do you have any final comments uh
or anything you'd like to address with
the audience before I guess we draw this
session to a close
sure yeah thanks I mean first of all
just to thank those who attended for
attending uh and good to uh to so thanks
for the great questions as well
um also thanks to lab roots and also to
maxsite
um language hosting of course and Mac
site uh obviously for sponsoring but
also you know we've been working with
maxite for many years now when we
started dabbling this in this main
display area some time ago and you know
the support has really been excellent
from from top to bottom so you know
we're really grateful for that and for
the continued relationship so thank you
and we want to thank you also as well
Peter for your time today and for your
important research
um this it's it's been a great
partnership and we've been very
appreciative of the work we've been able
to do with you so we would also like to
thank lab roots for supporting today's
educational event but before we go I
would like to thank the audience as well
for joining us today and for their very
interesting questions for the questions
we didn't have time for that might come
on on those submitted on demand we will
be addressing those by the speaker via
contact information provided by the at
you from you by the time of registration
the webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab Roots will alert you with email when
it's available for the replay we do
encourage you to share this event with
email to your colleagues who may have
missed the event today and visit
maxsite.com to learn more about our
technology so until next time thank you
very much and have a good day